but were you making money at a young age
yes my first paycheck was like 2.5 k
that's crazy yeah and my mom didn't know
like what I did or even how I like was
making money she was like you should get
a job I was like and then uh she sees my
first paycheck of like 2.5 k and she's
like what do you do and I was like Mom
14 I live stream so she got sussed out I
owe me too he's like what do you mean
you live stream as a 14 year old what do
you do what are you doing on live she's
not wrong that is pretty sus yeah no
then she started watching my live
streams and the reason I started live
streaming was because I didn't have any
friends I was like averaging thousands
of viewers concurrently really so how
did you make money on uh you know tips
so you're getting tips yeah